welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division released a new
trailer ahead of its premiere on disney
plus january 15th marvel's first
official installment of a phase four
that just got way more exciting
making it all the more intriguing that
we still know practically nothing about
this wacky wanda sitcom deconstruction
but after i have combed through this
latest trailer frame by frame folks
there are actually a ton of huge details
way more than i thought
confirming elements of this mystery and
setting up how one division will reframe
the marvel cinematic universe in its
phase 4 debut and go to omaze.com
rockstars and enter for your chance to
win 20
000 for your dream pc and to support a
great cause
let's do this the opening shot of this
trailer shows wanda envisions suburban
home in this
pocket reality though notice it flickers
into view with flashes of blue and
magenta static
the same palette of static that was
revealed behind the peeling wallpaper
and all those official posters that i
have been breaking down
so the visual formula we should be on
the lookout for this blue magenta static
is the border between realities
a sign that everything on this side of
that border is a false
projection now the last trailer used the
1958 platter
song twilight time this one uses the
1967 monkeys
daydream believer set in a bit of a
pattern here like if there were a third
trailer i would expect it to be a 70s
song dealing with sleep or dreaming ooh
maybe a song i love fleetwood mac's
dreams
now here you go again you say
you want your freedom vision followed by
an 80s trailer with
wham's wake me up before you go go
i am getting ahead of myself and i can
see you unsubbing due to my singing i'm
sorry anyway katherine han
plays agnes a name i have speculated
could be an amalgamation of agatha
and harkness act of the harkness being
the witch neighbor from the marvel
comics that i suspect this series is
based on
in which agatha harkness is a servant of
mephisto posing as a friend and
confidant
to wanda with her children but those
children are really just puppets used by
mephisto to try to take over her
notice how agnes here has this pendant
and no matter how much
this witch's costume changes through the
decades that pendant is
always there i suspect this necklace may
be connected to her link to mephisto
maybe even contain mephisto's presence
wanda suddenly remembers that she is
married to vision and an insert shows
her blinking rings on their fingers
back in the wide with agnes wanda still
has no ring
clearly wanda is not fully in control of
this pocket reality she is figuring it
out as she goes
then this overhead shot shows west view
apparently a
relatively new subdivision it is flat
treeless
but that it's definitely not the same
neighborhood as the opening shot so i
think the flatter neighborhood is
westview whereas
the more tree covered neighborhood is
east view and with each decade it looks
like wanda and vision move back and
forth between the neighborhoods
now in wanda's kitchen there is a
rooster on the wall because snl has
taught us that once you become a mom the
kitchen becomes a farm bathrooms are the
ocean
but soon you will know many things like
bathrooms are oceans but the kitchen
is a farm and if you are into bird clues
my poster breakdown goes into the
phoenix chicken
in that poster and it's parallels to
vision another kind of phoenix rising
from the ashes
wanda slides their two twin beds
together a meta joke about how in
sitcoms movies in the 50s they couldn't
show married couples sleeping in the
same bed
and now wanda is realizing how
ridiculous that is and she's merging the
beds the final shot actually shows this
bed as
one large bed one comforter covering
both of them just a little sign of her
recognizing the falseness of her world
now the reality begins to warp
around wanda turning technicolor just
like in pleasantville
including this interesting mural now
visible on the dining wall
it looks like a kind of mountain hotel i
might be wrong but those red
roofs white facades the beautiful
mountain view
folks i think that is colorado's stanley
hotel
famously the inspiration of stephen
king's overlook hotel in the shining
that is creepy for obvious reasons but
maybe a clue reflecting this couple
going a bit stir
crazy in this haunted house that is
trying to trap their souls
maybe this all will end with a black and
white picture on the wall and we'll
slowly zoom in and whoa there's an
android in there and as wanna turns we
get a clearer look at her new
baby bomb something i am going to guess
she did not have at the start of this
rotation because as the decades shift
forward they're likely gonna skip over
those fun details uh
like how an android vision made this
happen despite the fact that paul
bettany cannot stop talking about his
purple parts and interviews
but now foley prego in the brady bunch
home wanda kicks back using magic to
vacuum while reading
glamour magazine parody glamorous
headlines include if you look closely
lovely legs can take you anywhere make
him jealous
and he'll thank you later swimwear from
monaco and then there's a car ad on the
back american legacy with a red car
keep that in mind but notice here her
fingers cover another headline
the most something home furnishes i
think that covered word
is devilish with legs mcgee over there
being either wanda herself or
agnes thus that devil red color
another clue that this home is being
furnished by
marvel's devil himself mephisto that
magazine also appears on the coffee
table as vision and wanda dance
and then a shot that looks like the east
view neighborhood
red car in the driveway that appears
later in the 70s home that might be the
same car from that american legacy ad
but look over by the garage two bikes
and as wanda walks out it looks like she
is in that blue overall costume from the
roseanne kitchen shot in the big game
spot
if you look closely behind her two kids
it looks like
yeah we could be looking at our 90s set
up when wanda envisioned would have
those two kids in tween age years though
they are rumored to be young versions of
the mutants billy kaplan wiccan and
tommy shepard
speed as wanda's kids were later
revealed to be in the comics here's a
shot of the baby mobile
turning into actual butterflies and then
also in this nursery you can see the
crib in the background brady bunch
pregnant wanda feels the baby's kick
while eating oranges that's pristine
oranges are kind of an mcu big deal they
came up as a fun easter egg in avengers
endgame you can barely see them being
brought over by scott after clint did
that time trial which itself was a
callback to civil war
when scott lang brought up oranges as a
recovery food after his straining
power-up
does anyone have any orange slices also
eating oranges is said to improve your
memory
if this decade hopping wanda is playing
ketchup assuming she just has
amnesia or maybe an old sitcom on
pregnancy brain
she might be trying to eat oranges to
remember how the hell she got to where
she is
hell then a shot of agnes riding a bike
with a basket
style and then she gives vision a wink
as we meet her companion a new guy we
have not seen before
and like that other husband arthur hart
in the first trailer i do think it is
possible that all of these husband
figures could be shape-shifted forms of
mephisto i know what you're saying god
this idiot thinks everything is mephisto
just think of me as water boy kathy
bates everything's the devil everything
is the devil to you mama
it's just there's a lot going on that's
weird here
everything else has been a real
neighborhood they shot in but here the
backgrounds look
especially fictitious like tv set
backdrops and then as agnes winks it
makes the sound effect of a bike bell
ringing
huh hey by the way thanks to omaze for
sponsoring this video
omaze is a fundraising platform that
gives you the chance to win
once-in-a-lifetime experiences and
awesome prizes while raising money for
non-profit organizations
create your ultimate dream pc setup for
film editing working from home
or just going nuts on some noobs load up
on the fastest graphics cards multiple
monitors a gaming chair worthy of kings
landing
spend the due on any pc you want you
will be helping
pediatric patients through the bungee
foundation
and children's miracle network hospitals
the bungee foundation provides pediatric
patients with therapeutic entertainment
for play
and a sense of normalcy during
distressing situations
the children's miracle network hospitals
are a non-profit that supports
children's hospitals across the u.s and
canada providing health care to
10 million kids each year other
campaigns on omaze let you enter to win
a tesla
a 10-day tour of japan or lunch with ben
affleck and matt damon
and support causes like the special
olympics usa and the first responders
children's fund
for your chance to win twenty thousand
dollars for your dream pc
and support a great cause just go to
omaze.com
rockstars and the walls start to just
completely come down when
monica rambo visits and neither she nor
wanda know who she is
who are you i don't know i love how
smooth tiana paris is and transitioning
from that plastered smile to
abject terror and then a new overhead
shot shows us what i assume to be east
view again clearly a completely
different neighborhood than what
westview is but then
wanda's reality warping goes from simple
furniture choices to the whole structure
of the house itself the wooden framing
the brick chimney the wiring in the
walls and then we do this kind of
interesting digital zoom on wanda here
it makes me wonder if now we're seeing
the 2000s sitcom home a lot of 2000
sitcoms like modern family they're shot
in single cam
where they use more camera movements
like that then on halloween vision
wearing his classic yellow cape comics
costume
he notices more falseness of this
neighborhood specifically this neighbor
putting up decorations spelling off
about her honestly i might be wrong
is this not kate siegel from the honey
defill house and blind manor whoever
this is
she is definitely crying you can see
this tear trail going down her cheek
it's losing it then you can see at this
pool club a radio sends a message
through to wanda
this sounds like the voice of agent
jimmy wu and this is
further proof that wanda is not in
control of whatever is happening that
some
other dark force is hijacking her mind
and her reality warping powers
and i think we see that dark force in
the next shot the mystery beekeeper
even under the netting this person's
face is totally blacked out my theory is
well go with me my buzzy bees
this pocket reality is a kind of hive
wanda
is its queen bee she is the homecoming
queen of the monkeys song the queen
thinks she is master of the house but
looking down from above is actually
the beekeeper who is actually exploiting
this queen
and her drones and her workers to make
products for him
to take and feed on her workers vision
and agnes
her drones these other figures that she
blasts out of the hive to pollinate the
world
and the honey is wanda's chaos magic
unique to her and the beekeeper is
you know methisto hey i'll also give you
a nightmare but i'm pretty sure it's
medvista we just saw if it's doing the
loki trailer he's coming
tricking wanda into thinking she has
this beautiful home life when really his
goal is to drain her of her magic
there is another shot of wanda envision
looking out at what we assume to be the
static border of this pocket reality and
if you look very closely a
shadowy figure barely visible in that
static this figure appears to have a
kind of cape not unlike the capes worn
by people like mephisto or nightmare and
then agnes frantically
asks are you here to help us suggesting
she too has no idea why she's trapped in
this conspiracy bubble though it could
be an act from a duplicitous confidant
then there's a shot of vision wearing a
top hat wanda carrying a trophy we saw
this top hat in the poster clip
toy leak suggests that the two will
participate in a magic act at a talent
show but then notice that they are
wearing their technicolor transition
moment clothes that i talked about
earlier
wanda in this shot definitely isn't
pregnant so yeah i think that bump is
just gonna
come out of nowhere then we see him
swinging on the kids swing set then a
shot of armored trucks with mounted guns
i'm assuming these forces are military
forces with
sword the new agency consisting of
people like jimmy wu darcy lewis and
monica rambo military must see
some kind of active threat coming out of
this pocket reality then wanda and
vision finally start to sound like
avengers
this is our home then let's fight for it
nice i love seeing wanda float up like
this it looks like they just use a wire
stunt
instead of you know past floatings where
it's clearly vfx like notice there's
that solid peter pan shadow on the grass
there elizabeth bolton really had to fly
fun
however it is that wanda envisioned
sober up they are now
fighting for this dream that they're
trapped in i mentioned this in the
reaction it's similar
to that couple in eternal sunshine and
spotless mind when they resist the
erasure of the projected reality
just trying to cling together to make
this dreamy memory last as long as they
can
because they know when they wake up they
will no longer be together it's tragic
and it's beautiful we're all gonna cry
now one of the most interesting shots to
me is that helicopter flying past the
red
static wall things are looking real bad
from the outside
we could be looking at the cusp of the
event i have been speculating wanda's
full
psionic meltdown when she realizes this
reality is false and she can't keep it
causing the multiverse to
explode which i think will require
doctor strange and spider-man to put it
back together in spider-man home worlds
we'll see this title and doctor
strange's multiverse madness but by far
the craziest shot is this one of the
mind
stone and wanda's trance-like reaction
to it
a few things to note the yellow gem
initially has a blue
casing that shatters and breaks off it
remember when the mine stone was in loki
scepter it too was originally in a kind
of blue encasement
this was before marvel decided oh snap
let's make this infinity stone connected
oh but shoot we already got a blue one
so
i guess when ultron yanks it out of the
scepter it'll just turn yellow and then
all of those sheep will just go with it
and we did and look at wanda here a bit
more emaciated tired eyes
unwashed hair gray garb plain background
folks
we are looking at wanda back in her very
first mcu appearance the post-credits
scene of 2014's captain america winter
soldier when she and her brother
quicksilver pietro maximoff were
locked away inside hydra's lab in
sokovia this is the moment list and von
trucker use that mindstone to experiment
on them
and activate her sorcery to make her the
scarlet witch
this series is apparently going back to
that origin point and re-explain what
was
at the time an intentionally nebulous
backstory because marvel then was not
allowed to use the word mutant which
wanda maximoff is in the comics
so i expect this flashback to explain
how wanda already has sorcery in her dna
as hinted at recently by the wakanda
files book and a cosmic radiation from
the mind stone
activated those dormant abilities and
that mind stone connection
is what links her to her love vision who
was also brought to
life by that same mind stone now i also
did frame by frame breakdowns just like
this one for the loki trailer the falcon
winter soldier trailer and i'm not done
folks there is star wars news to talk
about
even more crazy details from all this
marvel news that we got to talk about
you gotta be here for all of it you can
do that by subscribing to new rockstars
hit that notification bell you can also
support us by checking out our great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
so many cool designs follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars thank you for
watching
boom boom you looking for this boom are
you looking for this boom i think
something's wrong here
[Music]
you